welcome back to new rock stars and live
from my mom's house i'm tommy bechtold
and the fantastic four
is the marvel reboot we're all looking
forward to from the mcu phase four
whether you're dreaming of reed richards
played by john krasinski or now older
and wiser miles teller no
thank you the reason we're just so eager
for the homecoming of marvel's first
family is
the past versions blue they let us down
the 2015 josh trank reboot was
incomprehensible the 2005 and 2007
versions feel
very pre-mcu plus there's some casting
controversies with the human torch and
captain america being the same person
but what if i told you
there was an earlier weirder more
incomprehensible cluster
that laid the groundwork for these
future iterations i give you
roger corbin's masterpiece from 1994
the fantastic four which i am going to
be examining
with a bootleg breakdown tell me what
the f
is a bootleg breakdown bootleg
breakdowns is where we dive deep into
the scummy pawns of the cheesiest
campiest cult classicist movies that
make eric voss go
hmm this sounds like a fun project for
tommy but
from the ashes of his indifference a
hero will rise that's right now that
uncle tommy has control of the wheel
i'm gonna take this movie and break it
down scene by scene just like eric voss
does however
instead of this fun little easter egg he
might give you from a star wars movie or
a good marvel movie i'm gonna find you
some
cow patties and outrageous hilarious
moments that make you go why was this
movie ever made
it's cringe clobbering time
the movie actually gets off to a solid
start with the opening credits imagery
of the cosmos sweep across the screen
there's a soaring musical score the
composing duo the worst brothers which
is the worst
name a composing duo for a movie like
this could possibly have they weave
together some light-hearted adventurous
songs
to make a pretty decent score this is
literally the only thing i kept
muttering to myself that was positive
about this makeup saying the music
is actually pretty good which is a
pretty low bar when you're watching a
movie that is meant to be taken in
visual
incredibly the worst brothers actually
went six thousand dollars out of their
own pocket to hire a full orchestra to
complete the score
visually the movie begins in a college
classroom reed richards and victor
vaughan hold the doom for now our
friends
and lab partners at their college ben
grim is their classmate in comic relief
we learned that colossus a radioactive
cosmic-like energy comet will be passing
nearby earth and victor sees this as a
can't miss opportunity to test out their
lab project of some unnamed device
reed richards thinks they need more time
because he's a stick in the mud and
that's why his hair is going to go grey
prematurely victor reluctantly agrees
but you know victor's a bad boy he ain't
gonna play by the rules their
intellectual friendship is accurate to
the original kirby and lee comics as is
the corniness of reed richards i mean
that is
ripped straight from the pages of those
original comics at the end of the
opening scene the camera uncomfortably
lingers on these two guys who seem to
have taken an interest in victor and
reed were given no
information as to who they are or what
they want pretty cool
for a movie now i'm all about mysteries
and solving them but just watch this
it's an uncomfortable amount of time
that the camera settles on them with
some like whimsical music
[Applause]
[Music]
next we head to mrs storm's boarding
house which is a dorm for college
students
and a functioning family home which
sounds like an absolute nightmare for
the storms there's no sign of franklin
storm here just
mrs storm sue johnny and for some reason
ben grimm and reed richards the age
difference between sue and reid is
substantial at this point in the movie
so their relationship is much more big
brother little sister than it is uh
creepy i mean sue clearly has a crush on
reid but he doesn't reciprocate in any
weird ways
he's dreamy you're gross
it's like we said the knight of colossus
is passing by her so sue and johnny take
their telescope to see colossus
reed heads to the lab to meet with
victor rita's still worried about
whatever this machine is they won't tell
us so we just have to assume it's a
complex piece of machinery
we're going to harness the energy of
tomorrow reed is cautious and victor's a
bad boy he's drunk with power do you see
where this is headed have you seen this
before
shockingly or not things go awry and
colossus is too powerful for whatever
this machine is victor is gravely
injured but reed is saved by ben grimm
the effects in this scene feel at least
a decade too updated for what it is
obviously this is due to budgeting the
movie had a budget of one billion
dollars
not enough money to make a marvel movie
okay so at the hospital ben is treated
for his wounds and reid is also
recovering when they are greeted by a
doctor who gives them
the bad news the burns were
too severe why does this guy look so
familiar oh right
it's the creep from the beginning scene
who is this guy we still don't know
friend comforts we read will the creepy
doctor and assistant steal victor's body
which
we learn is still alive and just like
that
it's 10 years later take that avengers
end game five years is for suckers ben
and reid are discussing a mission and it
looks like the ship from victor and
reid's drawings are what is gonna be
flown into space
ben is a little dubious about flying
this thing but that might just be
because the blab that reed is working on
him
looks like it took place in star trek
the original series we're looking at
some pretty dated technology
reid found the pilot he needs but he
also needs a crew so naturally he has to
ask
johnny and sue who they last saw as kids
johnny has gone from age 8 to 30 in 10
years but reid hesitates to bring them
on the mission
until he discovers that sue has turned
into an absolute smoke show
she got hot it's game on from there but
not before mrs storm gives us this
look at you the fantastic four
why anyway the next scene introduces us
to the mole man which of course we can't
call him because
this movie cannot afford the rights so i
guess we're gonna call him the jeweler
both the jeweler and dooms goons who are
incidentally the doctor in orderly from
the earlier scene and the guys from the
very beginning of the movie
are all trying to steal a diamond that
reed is gonna use to pilot his ship
ben grimm crashes into a blind woman
destroying her statues and she
is devastated oh my work
ben then helps her off the ground by a
man handling her those of us that are
fans of the comics know that this must
be alicia masters but
we do not find that out from this scene
because that would require information
next we blast off to space with a
brilliant scientist
an air force quality pilot and two
people that the scientists felt he owed
a trip to space to things go awry since
the real diamond has been stolen by the
jeweler and replaced with a fake diamond
and the ship explodes in a special
effects masterpiece and the fantastic
four
fall to earth amongst the wreckage of
the ship unbelievably the fantastic four
survived the crash without so much as a
scratch
i gotta say reed richards calls this out
and it's actually kind of refreshing
given that the genre that this movie is
in often shrugs its shoulders at the
miraculous
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free it has zero calories yet
tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from
they even have caffeine free beverages
for folks that want to drink one any
time of the day
me personally i drink mine after
midnight because i'm a freak baby let's
go one of these great flavors is star
blast it's like a
summer day there's some watermelon in
there there's some berry flavors
it kicks butt man i'm telling you this
is good there are days when i'm dragging
and need a little get up and go
a can of bang energy helps pick me up so
i can get work done it's a pep in my
step
a lot of you know i recently started
taking my health a lot more seriously
and bang energy
has been essential check out bang on
instagram you can get 25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code
newrockstars25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea
and keto coffee flavors you also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang self
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25
off when you go to bang energy.com and
use the code
new rockstars25 bang energy.com
using the code new rockstars25 the
fantastic four's powers begin to
manifest
meanwhile the rest of the world
immediately mourns for the fantastic
four and alicia masters
is instantly tasked with making a
memorial statue in honor of them the
delivery guy
who comes over to drop off the materials
to make the heads is like they just
deserve a true memorial
this is incredible turnaround from the
local government to get this statue
commissioned my town argued for 25 years
whether or not someone could open up a
wendy's here
happy ending we are dining on baked
potatoes and frosties
every night here okay unfortunately
alicia is captured by the jeweler's
henchmen who will do
anything for their horny boss the army
comes to rescue the fantastic four
and we finally say goodbye to ben grimm
and
hello to the thing the thing's practical
costume is the highlight
of the movie most of the budget went to
the making of this thing costume and
it's fully articulated face the
practical costumes were done by john
vulich and everett burrell who created
the zombie effects
for the night of the living dead remake
considering the time and budget
constraints the thin costume with a
completely emoting face is
actually pretty impressive they used
servo motors inside the face to make the
lips move up and down and
eyes move up and down it actually looks
pretty good the fantastic four are
examined by
a doctor or a guy who bought a doctor
costume we immediately discovered that
the doctor is actually on doom's payroll
and doom has decided that he is going to
take all the fantastic four's powers
and give it to himself in true super
villain fashion he talks about doing
this for a lot longer than he actually
spends tempting to do it
why doom tells his two special friends
that he's come to new york to get the
diamond from the jeweler which he will
use to transfer the power from the
fantastic four
to himself because science i guess the
fantastic four figure out that they're
being held by doom they realize the only
way they can escape is if they work
together
this shouldn't be a huge realization
since they were already a tight-knit
crew
who refused to go to space without each
other and yet it is
and they are only able to succeed when
each member learns to use their powers
for the good of the whole squad instead
of just
themselves the fantastic four confront
dr doom in his lair which is a series of
recycled sets from old roger corbin
movies like carnosaur they escaping it
back to the baxter building where reed
makes a huge breakthrough reed discovers
that their powers are actually
amplifications of their weaknesses reed
stretches himself too
thin johnny is a bit of a hothead sue is
shy and feels invisible and ben
is always stoned i may have made the
last one up depressed thing goes for a
pity party walk this whole secrets was
literally filmed gorilla style after
shooting at rap for the day the guy in
the thing costume in this scene isn't
even the same actor who played the thing
in the rest of the movie it was a guy
who's like a casting assistant the crew
members begged him to put the suit on
which by the
way i do for free weekly sue's got
evidently tons of time so she makes the
fantastic four of their iconic blue
unitards the actress who played sue said
that this
and those tin foil spaces were literally
the only wardrobe that the actors did
not bring for themselves ben
meets the jeweler's henchmen and
stumbles into a very awkward wedding
ceremony where alicia is being forced to
marry the jeweler
reed searches through some files to
discover dr doom and victor fondue are
the same
person are you kidding me just then dr
doom shows up and
shoots all the jewelers henchmen we are
treated to no less than
three knockoff wilhelm screams they are
truly incredible
alicia then senses ben is in the room
and tells him a man she's
met one time that she loves him because
of course she does
this causes the thing to immediately
power down and turn back into bedroom
which is kind of a hilarious visual
because the actor who played ben grim
did not play the thing in the costume as
well that was a different actor who was
shorter and smaller so as the thing
turns back into human ben graham he
actually gets wider and taller in a span
of 10 seconds
literally doctor doom commands his goons
to kill ben grimm then changes his mind
and says let him go
kill him
let him go ben escapes to the streets of
new york where he immediately
and presumably permanently changes back
into the thing in an emotional moment dr
doom hacks onto the video screen of the
baxter building and
reveals his evil plan i think again it's
mostly inaudible
basically he's gonna wipe out new york
city unless the fantastic four
surrender the thing to his credit stuffs
his sorry in a sack and rejoins the team
reed then tells ben that doom is victor
and ben is like i don't give up
he's got my girl man let's go that
brings us to the final battle at the
latvarian lair of dr
doom the fantastic four are immediately
captured
dummies using their powers and the power
of christ just getting the power of
teamwork
the fantastic four break free and fight
the bad guys but it's too late doom
fires the laser
new york is toast unless oh god that's
the human torch's music human torch
claims this
i've been wanting to blow up that
destructor away since i was a kid huh
despite having
just discovered the rain now we are then
treated to the best special effects
1971 has to offer unfortunately it's
1994.
the effects are not good supposedly the
legend goes
the studio thought they were getting the
effects designer from independence day
to do the effects with this movie what
actually ended up happening is this was
the assistant to the assistant of
one of the people who worked on one of
the effects of independence day and
basically lied about his resume to get
the job
and they just let him do the effects and
by the time they tried to fix any of
them it was too late they were out of
money they had to work with what they
got so the result is
this
i don't know it's better than i could do
johnny stops laser and reed and doom
battle on a cliff until doom
slips and purposely falls laughing all
the way to his death
fun fact this scene was actually shot
months after rapping of principal
photography and only because the actor
played dr doom joseph culp
again harassed the producers into having
them finish it the movie ends with a
wedding and the goofiest scene in the
whole film when reed
waves his hand off the top of the
wedding limo and it extends up like a
wacky waving inflatable balloon man
it's super goofy and it's the perfect
ending to this movie because
just like us not taking it seriously the
movie does not take itself too seriously
give it a watch let me know what you
think also tell me what other forgotten
and terrible movies have slipped through
the cracks on this channel and you want
uncle tommy to review because this is
our time please just shoot me a comment
on discord by becoming a patron of our
patreon page patreon.com
slash new rockstars comment down below
your thoughts please make them positive
i'm very sensitive follow me on
instagram and twitter at tommy bechdel
follow new rockstars
and subscribe for more bootleg
breakdowns it's clobbering time
[Music]
you